entonces ya vimos dos maneras de
calcular las cosas intermedias
interpolación lineal y curvas debe ser
ahora profundizaremos en las matemáticas
detrás de ellas vamos a construir algo
que aprendimos en la lección sobre
modelado ambiental entonces si necesita
repasarlo da clic en la liga de abajo
empecemos con la versión más sencilla
interpolación lineal
vamos a enfocarnos en este segmento
sabemos que el valor de y en el cuadro 4
de 750 y el valor en el cuadro 8 es 190
pero cuál es el valor de llene el cuadro
5 o 6 o 7 la imagen nos dice que puede
ser representada como una función lineal
de x donde x corresponde al número de
cuadros las funciones lineales pueden
escribirse en forma pendiente ordenada
al origen de igual a mx + b donde m es
la pendiente y b es la ordenada al
origen ahora no sabemos la pendiente y
la intersección directamente pero
tenemos dos puntos en la recta que es
suficiente información para calcular las
ahora una vez que tenemos mv podemos
conocer para cualquier cuadro intenta el
siguiente ejercicio para probar tu
entendimiento sobre la interpolación
lineal usando la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen